hello and welcome to this session
of blockchain myself saurav and i'm part
of the simply lenti
what's in it for you today let's discuss
what are the issues
with today's current banking system how
bitcoin
has solved these issues and how bitcoin
is evolving
what is blockchain technology and what
are its features
like public distributed ledger how
encryption works
proof of work algorithm and mining and
we will also discuss certain use cases
of blockchain mining
now what are the current set of issues
in today's banking system
in order to do any transaction on a
banking channel today
it costs a very high transaction fees so
suppose you want to do a transfer of
money
from your account to someone's else
account through a banking channel
the bank might charge a fee for 200
transaction up to five dollars and this
receiver
will end up receiving 195 dollar which
in percentage terms
is a very high percentage of transaction
fee also
as of today there's a lot of scenarios
people
end up doing double spending for example
over here the user has
eight hundred dollars in her account but
she ends up sending
thousand dollars 500 each to two users
double spending is a unique problem
where digital money
is spent twice so what does it tend to
do is the user is able to make two
purchases
with the amount which is less than the
purchase value so in this scenario
the lady was able to buy a commodity
worth more than 800 dollars
though she only had 800 in her account
also the banking systems are prone to
hacking
hackers attack financial institutions
and gain
unauthorized access to data they can do
transactions on your behalf
which you are not aware of or they can
do the transfer of money to some
illegitimate accounts
in 2017 the number of frauds in india
through atm cards and net banking total
to 1785
each amounting to more than one lakh
rupee so if you see
the current banking system is prone to
so many
hacks that it can amount to huge cost of
money
now how bitcoin can solve these problems
now bitcoin
is a decentralized system so which
allows you to
do a value transfer transaction at a
lower transaction fee
as low as one dollar as compared to the
five dollar which the bank was charging
and at the end
the receiver receives the true value of
the amount which was
sent by the sender bitcoin follow a
decentralized system
where no third party like governments
banks or any other financial
intermediary is involved
during the transaction between the
sender and receiver
thereby reducing the cost of transaction
drastically and that is the primary
objective
of cryptocurrencies or technologies like
blockchain
which advocates the removal of
intermediaries
now bitcoin is a cryptocurrency that
runs on blockchain
now how bitcoin solved the problem of
double spending
double spending is avoided through the
basic structure of blockchain
which involves verification of
transactions so
in the previous example as we saw when
the user
transferred 500 to the first person
then she will not be able to transfer
the another 500
based on the basic validation of the
blockchain
and we will see how suppose you're
trying to spend the same bitcoin in a
second transaction
after the first transaction has been
confirmed the saturn transaction will
not get verified and does become
invalid and this will happen because
after the first transaction has been
confirmed
your balance will be verified in the
second transaction
your address identity will be validated
and
if suppose you are trying to spend more
than what the balance you have
the miners the validators of the
blockchain network will discard that
particular
transaction and will not add it to the
main blockchain
network thereby double spending becomes
as good as impossible in a blockchain
each block is linked to its previous
block
the transactions become invalid for a
specific bitcoin
which has already been spent so you
can't spend
the bitcoin which you have already spent
public ledger
a public ledger records all bitcoin
transactions
where it is accessible to everyone who
is associated with the system it is 100
transparent system any transaction
happening is visible on the public
ledger
once a user joins the blockchain network
he gets
a copy of all the blockchain
since its initiation or inception and
the first
block in a blockchain is called the
genesis block
though the public ledger is accessible
to everyone
only the user's address and the
transaction details are visible
to the users on the bitcoin network by
looking at the address you can't figure
out to whom this address belongs the
identity is secure
of the address owner this keeps
blockchain
safe from data tempering each block
on the blockchain is aware of who is its
previous block
and this with entire blockchain is
created even if a hacker tries to hack
one block it would have to change the
entire subsequent chain ahead
of this block which will require huge
amount of computation power for the
hacker
in order to make the changes across all
the blocks which is
next to impossible now what is
blockchain imagine two friends living
far away and would like to transfer
money
using blockchain technology blockchain
is a decentralized system
of secure and trusted distributed
databases
it's a distributed ledger which records
and shares the transaction details
across
many nodes which are part of the network
so that the data is not
modified so each and every transaction
which happens on a blockchain network it
distributed
across all the nodes on the blockchain
each and every participant has the same
copy of the ledger
and it's an immutable ledger once a
record or a transaction is registered
it cannot be modified blockchain was
originally introduced to timestamp
digital documents
and prevent tampering of records in
simple terms a chain of blocks
that contain information is is called
blockchain now when a transaction occurs
its related information
is recorded into a block so as you see a
transaction initiated
in one corner of the globe can get
registered on the block
and then that block is being verified
validated
by the miners of the public ledger and
then added to the main blockchain
a block contains aggregated transactions
in a single block which a miner has to
validate
and in lieu of that the miner gets
rewarded now let's take
a closer look at what all are the
components of a block so whenever we
talk about a blockchain
what is actually a block and what it
consists of now there are four major
components
each block contains a previous hash data
data is nothing but the aggregation of
the transactions
which are aggregated in the block a
nuanced value
and a hash of the block itself now what
is previous hash
previous hash is the attribute which is
connecting
a block to its previous block so the
previous hash
attribute consists of the hash value of
its previous block
data it consists the details of the
sender's address
the receiver's address and the
transaction amount so basically
there could be multiple transactions
amongst multiple senders and receivers
so each block will consist n number of
transactions and each transaction will
have a sender's address a receiver
address and a transaction amount
nonce so basically the bitcoin uses a
proof of work algorithm
and in order to execute the algorithm
nonce is a random value used to vary the
output
of the hash value so proof of work is
the process
of transaction verification done in
blockchain
hash hash is like a digital fingerprint
it is the fingerprint
of the current block now where it takes
an
input value of the previous hash the
data
and the norms and produces an output
value of fixed length so bitcoin network
uses sha-256 hashing algorithm to
generate a 256-bit length hash
and this is the output it looks
something like a hexadecimal value
now what are the features of blockchain
a blockchain is a decentralized public
distributed ledger that is used to
record
transaction across many computers so
this is a sample
transaction which you are seeing these
are set of three transactions a
transferring money to b
b to c and c to b a distributed ledger
is a database
that is shared among all the users who
are part of the blockchain network
the transactions are accessed and
verified by users
associated to the bitcoin network
thereby making it
less prone to cyber attack it is
actually enclosed within all the
participants who are part of the network
now let's take an example
where these bitcoin users are
transferring money so here we have
example
like bella is trying to transfer money
to john john is trying to transfer money
to elsa
and elsa is trying to transform money to
jack so these are the three transactions
which are to be initiated now suppose
these transactions
were being happening on a central ledger
and it gets corrupted so there is a
chance
of the data getting tampered to solve
this problem a public distributed ledger
plays a vital role
now it ensures that users part of this
cycle have a copy of the transaction
details
each user will have a copy of
each transaction bella john elsa jack
they all have the same ledger and this
is what
is called as distributed ledger everyone
is having the
same copy now in case one of the users
like elsa misplaces her transaction
detail
she can easily be corrected by the other
participants because they have the
golden copy the correct copy or if
either of them attempts to alter the
record
the alternate transaction copies with
the other users
will negate the alteration because they
will see
that amongst all the participants only
one participant is having a
different copy they will negate the copy
of the
user and they will rectify it encryption
blockchain eliminates
unauthorized access by using
cryptographic algorithm
sha-256 to ensure that the blocks are
kept
secure so sha-256 is the cryptographic
algorithm which is used
each user in the blockchain has their
own keys so any user which on boards a
typical blockchain network is always
provided with two set of keys one is
private one is
public private key is known only to the
sender
also it is used to confirm if the origin
of the transaction is
legitimate public key it is also used to
uniquely identify the user
but it is shared by the sender with
every transaction it floats on the
blockchain network and we will see how
now let's take a look
at a typical transaction verification
process suppose a sender wants to send a
message
he will pass the message through the
hash function and generate
a hash value of the message now after
the hash value is being
created it is passed through a signature
algorithm
and with the private key a digitally
signed document is created
now the transaction message original
message
the digitally signed document and the
public key are transmitted
to the receiver now at the receiver end
the transaction message is passed
through a hash function to get a
hash value and that hash value is
compared with the hash value
obtained by passing the digital
signature and public key through a
verification function
and then both the values are compared
now let's see how the hash function
works
the hash function creates a unique
digital fingerprint of data
you pass the message through the hashing
function and it generates a hash value
this hash value is called a digital
print it has a very unique property
any hashing function is a one way
function it cannot be reversed
you cannot decode the original value
from the
hashed value it is a one way encryption
so here are some examples
whatever be the size of the input data
the hash value
is always of 256 bit length and we will
take a look at the demo
at the end of this session where i'll
show you how to generate
a hash value using sha-256 now let's
consider an example
of gmail using hashing algorithm
whenever you
are entering the username and password
that password is never
directly persisted in any of the gmail
database it is persisted using
hashing function so once you have
created your password and again once you
log in
your password is again passed to the
hashing function
and compared with the hash value
persisted in the database
and once both these hash value matches
then only you are allowed to log in so
every time you log into gmail your
password is hashed
into a value and compared against the
one
stored in the database the hash values
match with the one in database and then
the inbox is displayed on your screen
now let's take a look of what is the
proof of work algorithm
proof of work is a method to validate
transactions
in a blockchain network by solving a
complex
mathematical puzzle and this whole
process is called mining
finding the nonce value is the
mathematical puzzle
that users or miners need to solve in
the bitcoin network so it takes huge
amount of computational power and
resources of the miner
in order to find out that nuance value
users trying to solve the puzzle are
called miners
the puzzle is solved by determining a
nonce
that generates a hash value and results
an output lesser than a target so in any
proof of work algorithm
there is always a target which is
predefined for a block
the miner has to use the nonce
in order to generate a hash which has to
be less than the target
miners verify transactions within a
block
and adds the block to the blockchain
when they have confirmed
and verified the transaction with proof
of work
miners compete against each other to
solve the mathematical puzzle
the first miner who solves the puzzle is
rewarded and when a block is solved the
transactions
contained in a block are also considered
valid and the bitcoins
associated with the transactions then
get deducted from the originator
or the sender and moves to the receiver
now let's see
how proof of work works so let's take a
look
at the block and its components the
previous block hash
it stores the hash value of the previous
block of the blockchain
data it contains the list of all the
transactions which have been aggregated
in the block
nonce is the random value which is used
to generate
a hash value less than the target and
hash is the digital signature of the
block itself
the hash is generated using a hashing
function called
sha-256 now using the nonce
when the hash is generated if its output
is less
than the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved
the block is considered to be validated
if not
then the miner increments the nonce by
value 1
and then again rehashes generate a hash
and
goes through the cyclic process till the
time it is not able to generate a hash
less than the target
in blockchain the target is adjusted
every two zero one six blocks which is
approximately every 14 days
the average time of block formation is
10 minutes and the difficulty target of
the puzzle
increases or decreases depending on the
time
it takes to mine the blocks so it is the
inbuilt network
which is generating the target for the
puzzle to get
solved and it fluctuates the difficulty
based on the time it takes to mind block
proof of work is hard to produce
but very easy for binders to verify so
point to be noted here is
once the block is hashed the remaining
miners
are supposed to validate the work which
one miner has
done but they are not required to find
the nonce again
so basically the miner who is supposed
to earn the bitcoin
has done the hard work but the others
miners on the network
just have to verify his validation in
blockchain
when miners use their resources time
money electricity etc
to validate a new transaction and record
them
on the public ledger they are given a
reward now that reward
is in bitcoins itself which as of today
stands at 12.5 bitcoins
and to add there is no other way that
the bitcoins
can be generated in a bitcoin network it
is only through mining
now the bitcoin network internally
halves the reward
after every 21k blocks which is
approximately every four years so now
subsequently whenever the time period
will end
the mining reward will get reduced to
6.25 btc
now let's take a look at a demo now as i
said
this is a demo to showcase how to
generate a sha-256 hash
using an input value so whatever input i
have the hash which is generated it is
of 256
bytes even if i add a new value
it will again only generate a 256
bit length hash now let's take a look at
a typical
blockchain structure we have a block
over here
which has one transaction added to it
now this is orange in color because it
has not been mined
and i can only add a subsequent block to
it
once it is mined now as this is the
first
block in this particular blockchain the
previous hash value
of this block is all zeros and it is a
called as a genesis block
now as i have mined this block the hash
which is the digital signature of this
block itself has been generated and i
can now
add a block primary thing which to be
noted over here is
that the previous hash value of this new
block is the hash value of the previous
block
it has two transactions aggregated in it
and i can
again mine it and now the hash of this
block has been
generated so this highlights the typical
data structure of a blockchain and how
blocks are linking themselves to each
other now let's take a look of a
typical transaction which happens over a
blockchain now i want to send money from
wallet 1 to wallet 2
and i want to send one dollar there is a
transaction
fee of point one dollar associated with
this transaction now as i have
initiated that transaction wallet one
has been deducted as one point one
dollar and it is a pending transaction
this transaction is waiting to be mined
so i can choose any of the miners to do
this transaction the pending transaction
is
done and now block 2 if you see
has been added the previous hash value
of this block
is 0 0 a 9 is the hash value of block
one
another thing to be noted the value of
the amount in wallet two has also got
incremented by one done again we can try
another transaction
transferring one dollar again from
wallet one
to wallet three and say from wallet 2 to
wallet 3 i have done a transaction it is
pending
it can be mined and block 3 has got
added now what are the key takeaways
today we learned what are the current
issues in the banking system and how
bitcoin solved them what is blockchain
features of blockchain
and the demo of the features which we
have seen i hope you had a great
learning session
and i'll meet you in the next session
thank you
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simply learn youtube channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here